so what we have here is a ball and you
imagine if I take this ball and bounce
it off the table bounce off that table
and if I do that exactly the same way
each time then what will happen is that
it'll hit the same point on the world
imagine if we had a million balls we
could control it so that each and every
one of them hit the table in exactly the
same way exactly the same velocity that
bounced off and we'd end up with a very
well-defined dent in the wall if we then
for example just scatter those balls
take them and fire them off at different
angles then what you'll find is that the
wall will cover up with different dents
in the wall and we'll end up with a sort
of random well a random distribution of
dents in the wall
electron is a negatively charged
particle and it is enormous ly important
Mendeleev didn't believe in electrons
he thought atoms were solid and you
couldn't break them and weren't made up
of anything else and he believed this
till he died in 1907 but electrons of
enormous ly important for chemists so
now if we imagine instead of we're in
the real world we shrink everything down
so this ball becomes a an electron we
can think of this as being an electron
what we actually find remarkably is that
we get these bands we've got this very
well-defined pattern of here where there
are lots of of dents here where they
weren't practically known here where
there are lots of dents again and those
bands were well-defined spacing or
well-defined separation why do electrons
behave so differently from little balls
and maybe that's because well actually
they're not little balls there's
something different from little balls
what could that be well let's go down to
the lab and we'll see another experiment
whereby we see these patterns and maybe
the patterns we see in that experiment
will help us to understand really what
these electrons are all right when I
teach the students in their first week
of coming to university I tell them
about electrons how they behave in atoms
and they find this is very hard because
electrons if you treat them one way
behave just like a particle an electron
is something a negative charge that can
be transferred between one atom and
another rather like changing money but
on the other hand if you want to
understand the stretch of the atom then
you have to treat the electron as a wave
hello George
what we have here is not an experiment
with electrons but we'll get to that
what we have here is an experiment with
light in this case we've got a laser the
important reason we're using the layers
or enough for example a light bulb is
that in the laser they are the photons
of light all come out in step so we've
got an obstacle through which those
photons those little packets of light
i've got a pass and so if you follow
this true you follow the path of light
down here
we have the light and instead of it all
piling up what we see is this pattern
exactly like data was discussing in
terms of the electrons and this is
something called a double slit
experiment with two slits here the key
thing here is that what we have is light
light is a wave a wave is coming true
and it's interfering constructively
destructively to form this type of
pattern the key thing here is related to
how those waves interfere with each
other but we see exactly the same
pattern in terms of this these bright
spots these dark spots when we do this
experiment with electrons and I'll
adjust to think well hang on if we're
seeing exactly the same patterns with
photons which are aware when we know
that as electrons then it leads us to
think well maybe the electrons are
actually not just little hard balls
little billiard balls they actually have
a wave-like nature and the problem is
that you have to explain the thing
mathematically and as soon as you go
into the maths the difficulty is that
unless people are very good
mathematicians and I'm not it's not very
clear what the equations mean everyday
common sense does not allow us to
describe it in simple words so the
concepts are too elusive and slippery
for the English language but it has
these particle-like qualities which it
always takes with it such as its mass
its momentum its spin its electron
electron number and so on and that
always remains so if a particle comes
along and hits something that is always
conserved and this quantity remains the
same but when it hits things it does so
as a wave scattering off things as they
or a wave so all the time it has these
two low Civ characters going on and I
don't know physics when you're 18 is
based on common sense but when you've
gone through all this
somehow you get used to it you don't
actually like it you just get used to it
and learn to live with it and that's the
language that seems to fit so back in
the office what we were doing was this
considering that if those electrons were
billiard ball like particles that when
we fire them at something they'll all
pile up in one place or they've spread
out randomly what we have here is the
actual experiment where we're taking a
sample and we're firing electrons of
that those electrons are bouncing back
from that sample and we're looking at
the pattern they form now if they were
little billiard balls and we wouldn't
expect to see what we'd expect to see
would be a random sort of splurge of
electrons that's not what we see what we
see are very very well-defined peeps and
those peaks and spots arise from the
weird like properties of the electron
and what we have here is instead of
having a slit like we had with the
experiment with the photons of light
what we're using because the wavelength
of where the wavelength of the electrons
is so much smaller is we're actually
using the atoms of a surface to diffract
the electrons one of the things which I
think perhaps students find particularly
difficult is that when you're treating
the electron as a wave you can't really
talk about it being there or there or
there because a wave is everywhere in
the volume that you're considering and
therefore the idea that everything is
very delocalised is difficult for people
to understand back in 1923 it was a
piece of kid who resembled this that
actually give us the really the
fundamental proof that electrons had we
have like characteristics and so it was
a couple of people called Davisson and
Germer managed to measure a pattern just
like this that we've got in here very
similar to this and they realized what
hang on that's that's a diffraction
pattern that means that the electrons
must be waves almost have wave-like
character